The word democracy does not mean government of the people
Demos mean debt
the populace You know,
the people who are alien bass,
it is not the people in the sense that love we give them
Kratos is the name of something you put in the nose of cows and
oxen to pull and if they don't advance in the nose naturally.
It is 1 toxic instrument
So what is democracy?
It is the control by force of the populace
That's what you want to do in Benin
There is the populace in Benin Since
the populace has 1 name,
it is the popular scum.
In fact,
it is the very hatred of the people that we made.
Athens,
the other great speakers
Athenians,
what were they doing when there were not enough slaves,
they went to war to deal with slaves That's why
there were only wars The Penelope War,
the big wars all the time.